[Music]
the Amish are fascinating it's hard to
imagine that people are still living in
these traditional communities in the
21st century while we live in a totally
different world but you will be even
more surprised to see that their lack of
technology is not the most unusual thing
you find in these villages make sure you
watch this video until the end to see
what happens when they get a chance to
see what the modern world looks like if
this is your first time visiting our
channel don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
today we are showing you 10 facts about
the Amish the world ignores the baptism
tradition you probably know that the
Amish are Christians but the one thing
that sets them apart from Christianity
that we all know is the lack of
evangelism and the adult baptism
even though religion is really important
to them they think that they cannot
baptize babies who cannot choose for
themselves that's why an adult has to
make the decision to become a Christian
Amish usually choose to be baptized on
their own between 18 and 22 years old
but to be accepted they first need to go
through an 18 week instruction period
it's really important for them to do
this to be part of the community because
that's the only way that they're allowed
to marry another Amish their baptismal
vows are what makes them accountable to
the church for their lives if they're
not interested in religion anymore they
will be rejected from their community
and will have to leave the only people
they ever knew in their village however
before their baptism they can still
leave their village and come back
because Amish respect the voluntary
decision to join the church so baptism
is probably one of the most important
commitments they will ever make as they
make the decision to spend their rest of
their lives in this community and we
think that this is what makes adult
baptism so beautiful this occasion means
much more when you choose to be part of
this and remember this wonderful moment
forever
the faceless dolls some Amish toys look
like they come directly from a horror
movie if you're afraid of dolls you're
not ready to see these strange faceless
characters but why do their dolls look
like that it's because giving a face to
a toy is associated with pride and
vanity they don't want to create an idol
image of the human form they also
consider that giving a face to a doll
would be a graven image of a human and
the Bible forbids it
some people also have more unusual
beliefs they think that the dolls can be
possessed by evil
are demonic entities the toy could then
watch the child and their family through
their eyes they have no eyes no mouth no
ears and no hands so they can't see
they're not able to communicate they
can't hear us and they will never try to
grab us don't worry this is just a
superstition but it could still explain
why old dolls look so scary and even
though faceless dolls are supposed to be
safer we think that this is what makes
them even more terrifying maybe that's
why some Amish kids play with normal
dolls anyway they are not baptized yet
so they don't really have to follow
every role no matter what we think that
we're going to play with the toy cars
instead they're less scary the music
have you ever heard Amish music if you
have there might be a problem because
these people don't have the right to use
musical instruments that's because it's
viewed as a means of self-expression and
it would be associated with pride in
superiority they think that
self-expression calls for unnecessary
attention to the individual and they'd
rather work together as a group but that
doesn't mean that you won't hear them
sing they love singing on different
occasions after meals while working in
the evening at school and have any
important social events and most of the
time it's an expression of praise to God
their Church songs derive from the
Ostend
which is the high german songbook passed
on from generation to generation they
can also sing in English just for fun as
a way to pass time for example when they
work or when they take a shower however
you'll notice that there is no musical
note it said that the dominant tone
found in most of these songs is one of
deep loneliness great sorrow or protests
against the world of wickedness but you
will be surprised that some of them do
listen to popular songs mostly country
music they don't own an iPhone but just
like us they can't help themselves from
listening to some of the most popular
hits when they're in a car the photos
there's a reason why you don't see a lot
of pictures of Amish even though a
reality show just broke all the rules as
we have said previously graven images
are forbidden by the Bible they can't
reproduce the work of God taking a
picture could also be seen as a show of
pride which is not acceptable in their
community this is why you can see a sign
asking you not to take a picture if you
visit an Amish community and no matter
what you see it's important to respect
them in their tradition however everyone
is different and some Amish are more
comfortable with photography for example
some don't mind being photographed if
their face isn't shown if you watch some
documentaries you will notice that their
face is never shown directly on camera
the camera is often on the side of their
face obscured others think that there is
a difference between someone posing for
a picture like for a selfie and someone
photographed in a natural setting they
don't have our problem with being filmed
or photographed at a wedding or on a
special occasion as long as they are not
posing some of them also don't mind
taking pictures of children because they
are not get baptized members of the
church so no matter what it is always
polite to ask someone if you can take a
picture of them whether they are Amish
or not the education don't think that
Amish are not educated they just learn
things in a different way in each
village you can find a school with one
or two rooms teachers are there to help
children until eighth grade then if men
want to find a job and women wants to
become good housewives other grownups
will have to teach them how it's done
this is how boys learn how to be farmers
tradesmen homemakers and carpenters
while girls learn how to cook a full
meal and take care of the children just
like us they will learn everything they
need to know when they are teenagers and
they will be ready for adulthood Amish
think that this education is practical
because kids learn faster with their new
experiences they are also needed at an
early age to do certain jobs so their
parents don't want to see them at school
for too long but they also have
religious objections they think that
higher education can promote ideas
counter to Christian values Amish do you
agree that we need professionals like
doctors in our society however their
community is so small that they don't
feel like their children need this kind
of education and they will simply seek
the help of a professional outside their
village only if needed so there are pros
and cons but as long as it's their
decision to live this way and they are
still functional it doesn't have to be
wrong the ordinal the Amish life is not
as simple as you might think
even though anyone can have the chance
to join if they show their commitment to
the church and are accepted by the
community they have to follow a code of
conducts called the ordinal and just to
make things more complicated it is not
written and it is not even part of the
Bible it is simply the result of many
years of history and it can be different
in each community this is what teaches
them the virtues of obedience
and simplicity it also keeps them away
from self-expression pride and indeed
some things could also be forbidden like
public electricity divorce
suing in a court of law running for
political office and owning certain
technologies like a telephone in their
home after all the purpose of Orden hung
is to uphold the communities they feel
that it wouldn't be worth it to be part
of a community without rules that
accepts everyone so what happens when
you violate the ordinance you will first
be asked to cease the deviant behavior
but you also risk being rejected by your
family and your community but don't
worry people can always come back as
long as they make a confession to prove
that they won't make the same mistake
again the fashion what people wear is
also part of the ordinance
the Amish clothing is plain and humble
to make it harmonious with their simple
and separated lifestyles it's usually
home made from simple fabrics which
could make it look like it comes from
the past women traditionally wear long
sleeves full solid colored skirts and
aprons some communities might even
dictate the exact length of a skirt they
also wear their hair in a braid or a bun
and cover it with a small bonnet the
hair of Amish women and girls should
always be covered in public and you will
never see them wearing jewelry or
pattern clothes men usually wear really
simple straight cut suits pants and a
hat if they want to they're not allowed
to have pockets collars ornamentation
buttons belt loops or belts this is why
most of them wear suspenders if there is
one positive thing to say about Amish
fashion it's that it's easy to see who
is single
that's because married men are required
to grow their beards and married women
wear dark bonnets in any case they
shouldn't use fashion to show pride
express themselves or draw attention
this is what teaches them to focus on
qualities other than appearance they
might be a little too strict but we
think that some people in our society
should be more like them the wedding
this is probably one of the most
interesting events in this community and
it's nothing like we're used to seeing
in the modern world we know that Amish
are only allowed to marry once they're
baptized and when they find the perfect
partner the engagement is kept secret
until it's announced in a Sunday church
service usually four to six weeks before
the wedding this is what they call
publishing the engagements then they
hand deliver all the wedding invitations
to each potential guests
however Amish women don't
the chance to go shopping for their
wedding dress they have to make it
themselves and unlike most of us they
will wear a blue dress but some
communities allow them to wear any color
they want after their wedding it will
become their Sunday Church attire and
they will also be buried with their
wedding dress a cape and an apron when
they pass away as Amish don't wear
jewelry there is no exchange of rings
and an Amish marriage and stop thinking
about a romantic honeymoon after their
wedding couples usually spend the
weekends visiting all their relatives
and this is when they collect the
majority of their wedding gifts and
there's also one good reason why you
should be happy to be invited to a
wedding if you're a teenager it's used
as an opportunity for matchmaking and
feature couples will be assigned
specific seats in order to bring them
closer the weight obesity is a big
problem in America but have you ever
noticed that almost all the Amish are
thin weight problems might be genetic
but they found a way to avoid it by
living away from the modern world they
might eat more bacon than you do as they
enjoy every part of the pig with
potatoes and pies so their diet doesn't
really explain their healthy ways but
what is their secrets it is simply
physical activity the fat jeans have no
effects for those who've earned 900 more
calories with physical exercise every
day and they can easily burn them by
simply walking around the village or
working on the farm
Amish men walk 18,000 steps per day
compared to most American men who take
fewer than 20 steps between their house
and their car unfortunately Amish
housewives might gain a little weight as
they simply do chores around the house
but no matter what obesity is far more
important in the modern world than it is
in the Amish community if you're looking
for a new diet maybe you should try
spending a month with them your weight
might be written in your genes but not
in the Stars your ancestors had the same
genes but it's when our society changed
that it became a problem this is why
going back in the past could be a good
way to lose a few pounds the Rumspringa
you might think that when you have
always lived in the Amish community
you can't know if you want to live in
the outside world or not this is why
baptism wouldn't really be a decision as
Amish don't have any other choice but
you would be wrong
when Amish teenagers turn 16 they have
the chance to experiment and explore for
a limited time
period usually a year they are allowed
to break the rules and visit the modern
world outside of their culture to see if
they would like to live in a different
way for example they can go to the local
theatre or take driving lessons during
this traditional rite of passage but
people notice that the new trend is now
creating a facebook profile as soon as
they have the chance to use the Internet
they quickly embrace modernity so it
seems like this is what they miss the
most in their community the purpose of
the Rumspringa is to learn enough to
help them make the most important
decision of their lives
if they want to be baptized join the
church and never live in the modern
world again however as they are not
adapted to this new world if most Amish
decide to stay with their families are
there any other surprising things that
you know about the Amish community don't
be shy to tell us what it is in the
comment section down below
we'd love to hear what you think and
that's it for 10 facts about the Amish
the world ignores for more stories like
this make sure you watch fifteen ways
the Internet has changed your life
thanks for watching and see you next
time
[Music]